yeah another year another paranormal
activity right no new Paranormal
Activity trailer but it's not for a
Halloween it's actually for January now
we have a trailer for Paranormal
Activity not 5 it's actually Paranormal
Activity the marked ones yeah there is
still gonna be a Paranormal Activity 5
next October I guess but this is not it
this is a spinoff it's not shoot it's a
sidequest it's like when Nintendo came
out with the D s and they were like no
it's not actually part of the Gameboy
family that's something else this is
kind of like it's not actually it but it
is an in Paranormal Activity the marks
ones it starts out you're like this is
Project X right they got the parties and
the found-footage [ __ ] that's all the
rage these days if someone dies and
these kids are like let's go into her
apartment holy [ __ ] just a bunch of
Voodoo stuff and one kids like hey I've
got bit that's weird now I have
superpowers chicken'll is it looks like
a like a bite or something
no this isn't Chronicle - its Paranormal
Activity the marked ones
yeah Chronicle the marked ones I imagine
Chronicle jokes are gonna be flying
around the internet because that's what
this looks like this kids like holy [ __ ]
I have super-strength
come on although I should actually be
excited that they're taking this in a
new direction because it is a new
direction because Paranormal Activity 4
was stupid seriously watch this I'm
psychic no-one's gonna raise their hand
show of hands who gave you [ __ ] about
paranormal activity for I know you
didn't did you you right there stop
typing I cared about paranormal activity
for you just had to go ahead and put
that in the comment section didn't you
alright you right there stop do not give
that comment a thumbs up you did okay
alright fine this is the internet
whatever so they're taking the
Paranormal Activity franchise in this
other direction which should be cool the
problem is the Paranormal Activity
movies at this point are in a no-win
situation making other Paranormal
Activity movies like Paranormal Activity
4 it's gonna be like Paranormal Activity
4 it's gonna be crap you make it
different and now you're emulating the
other paranormal activity found footage
scary movie ripoffs that also come out
in January that aren't so good either
and that's not good either so it's just
it's a no-win situation for paranormal
activity I want to treat paranormal
activity at this point like I treat saws
like alright cool alright we had our
trilogy but instead of letting it die
like a responsible studio they're like
no we will get a new movie even if we
have to make it a little different
advocate with superpowers who pulls a
piece of string out of his eyeball
yeah that's that's pretty gross this kid
in this movies like I'm bullying string
out of my eyeball that's really gross
and wait a minute if I become a street
magician and do this on the Vegas trip I
can get a lot of desperate Vegas [ __ ]
so Paranormal Activity the mark ones is
actually the untold true story of Criss
Angel Mindfreak this trailer does have a
couple of cool scenes like the ceilings
sylars out in front of the car
disappears you're like we're two goalies
[ __ ] he's there that's actually really
cool I think if this movie concentrates
on more moments like that let's say
these kids have to get from point A to
point B the entire movie is a bunch of
really close quarters scary [ __ ] of them
traveling and scariness and ghosts
that's not confined to a house it might
be cool we got to remember what this
movie is it's a scary found footage
movie that's coming out in January
January is when scary movies come out
that weren't good enough to be October
scary movies in the end we're still
gonna get Paranormal Activity five which
means we'll have six Paranormal Activity
movies which means this franchise has
truly gone the route of saw right so
Paranormal Activity the marked ones have
you seen this trailer and what do you
think about it do you think this kids
actually Criss Angel oh my god that's
close whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you